ahora que tenemos un entendimiento
conceptual de lo que una integral de
superficie puede ser quiero pensar en
cómo construir un vector unitario normal
porque cuando queríamos calcular esta
esta integral de superficie necesitamos
encontrar un vector unitario normal a
esta superficie para poder hacer este
producto
/ efe y n entonces esa pregunta nos
queda y vamos a resolverlo primero
suponiendo que esta superficie está
parametrizar a esto es que la superficie
es ese perdón en realidad es la imagen
de una función vectorial r que depende
de dos parámetros o ive ahora ya que
tenemos esto lo que tenemos que ver es
cómo cambia r sobre cada una de las
direcciones vive es decir queremos ver
cómo como es r
ok la la derivada de r respecto de u y
como es
r
es decir la derivada de de r respecto
debe ok entonces si consideramos esto de
esta forma vamos a ponerlo sobre la
superficie para verlo claramente
entonces tomemos un punto y coma ok ese
punto v después de aplicarle la función
r es en realidad un vector sobre esta
esta superficie ok
ahí está rv entonces si yo vario es
decir en la dirección en la dirección y
a lo mejor me da un punto por aquí ok
no sé cuál sea déjenme ponerlo más claro
este me da este punto de aquí y pues eso
me determina un vector cierto este
vector que es hereu que resulta de ver
cómo cambia el el vector r sobre la
dirección u y por lo tanto como es una
derivada estamos hablando de un vector
tangente a la superficie ahora bien cómo
cambiaría el el bueno si quieren vamos a
hacerlo un poquito más grandes por
ejemplo vamos a pintarlo de este lado
ok más o menos así se vería el vector r
muy bien ahora pensemos lo mismo pero en
la dirección b es decir cómo cambia el
vector r cuando nos movemos sobre la
dirección b entonces no sé a lo mejor es
un punto aquí y esto me determina un
vector citó que pues no sé cómo sea a lo
mejor lo podemos representar
de esta forma que aquí está el r&b otra
vez este vector r&b como estamos
hablando de vectores derivada entonces
es tangente a la superficie y es
tangente sobre la dirección b entonces
estos dos vectores estarán generando
digamos si tomamos combinaciones
lineales de ellos están estarán
generando un cierto plano un cierto
plano y como estos dos son vectores
tangentes a la superficie en realidad
están generando un vector perdón un
plano tangente un plano tangente a la
superficie en este punto sobre de ella
entonces en realidad pensemos ahora en
lo siguiente si yo quiero un vector
ortogonal o normal a la superficie en
realidad estoy pensando que sea
ortogonal o normal es lo mismo
a todo el plano tangente en ese punto
entonces si yo me tomo un vector aquí un
vector normal a este plano ya estaría
encontrando el vector o más bien uno de
los vectores normales a la superficie
entonces basta con tomarme el producto
cruz de estos dos vectores para
encontrar uno que sea ortogonal a la
superficie ok
como vemos el producto cruz bueno pues
no sé si recuerden esto de la regla de
la mano derecha déjenme hacer todo mi
mejor esfuerzo para dibujarlo en serio
estoy viendo ahorita aquí mi mano mi
mano derecha para poder dibujarlo por
ejemplo aquí
mi dedo pulgar
se los juro estoy haciendo mi mejor
esfuerzo ok
ahí está mi dedo pulgar y voy a tener
por aquí mi dedo índice
déjenme ponerlo un poquito más más claro
porque quiero pasar un dedo por encima
de él entonces este es mi dedo índice
sale muy bien ahí está mi dedo índice y
lo que estamos haciendo es es considerar
que mi dedo el que está en medio el dedo
el dedo de medio de la mano este dedo en
realidad está apuntando digamos hacia
adentro está apuntando hacia adentro de
dónde están los otros dos entonces éste
en realidad estará apuntando más o menos
de esta forma
como lo estoy viendo
ok ahí está mi dedo el dedo de en medio
y aquí tengo el resto de los dedos pero
eso es bueno no importan mucho
los otros dos dedos
y bueno aquí estaría
de la mano
ok entonces en realidad estamos poniendo
aquí digamos el rv sobre este el dedo el
dedo pulgar y si ponemos el r&b r&b
el revés sobre el sobre el dedo índice
hacia donde apunta el dedo el dedo el
dedo de en medio es en dónde está hereu
cruz r&b ok entonces de esta forma con
la regla de la mano derecha espero le la
agarre en la onda mi dibujo es cómo
podemos determinar la dirección hacia
donde apunta ok entonces ya que tenemos
esto dicho este es uno de los tantos
vectores normales a la superficie
ok este es un vector normal no es único
ahorita tenemos por ejemplo si tienen
uno en una dirección si lo estiran o lo
encogen también son vectores normales
entonces de estos solo queremos
considerar aquel vector de hecho este de
aquí este de aquí es un es un vector que
es ortogonal o perpendicular tanto a
hereu
como hervé ok entonces lo que queremos
encontrar es ahora un vector pero que no
sólo sea eso ahora ojo lo de la regla lo
de la regla de la mano derecha es porque
tenemos dos vectores digamos o dos
direcciones posibles la que apunta hacia
afuera como está aquí en el dibujo o la
que apunta digamos hacia dentro de la
superficie ok entonces después de que ya
tenemos este vector seleccionado yo
quiero uno que sea unitario es decir
cuya norma sea 1
cómo hago eso pues voy ahora sí a
definir con todas todas mi vector
unitario que de hecho está definido en
cada punto
b ok y este va a ser pues simplemente
este vector que tenía
hereu cruz
rb
y ahora lo que voy a hacer es dividir
este vector entre su norma de esta forma
estaría garantizando que estoy
recortando lo recortando lo tanto como
sea posible para que este nuevo vector
ok
este nuevo vector que defino como hereu
cruz
rv sobre su norma esto ya tiene norma 1
verdad porque la norma de o más bien un
vector dividido entre su norma ya tiene
norma 1 ok de esta forma hemos
construido ya un vector normal unitario
en cada punto de la superficie y espero
que haya quedado bastante claro de cómo
hacerlo